So, we're going to talk today
about binary search trees.
It's something called randomly
built binary search trees.
And, I'll abbreviate binary
search trees as BST's throughout
the lecture.
And, you of all seen binary
search trees in one place or
another, in particular,
recitation on Friday.
So, we're going to build up the
basic ideas presented there,
and talk about how to randomize
them, and make them good.
So, you know that there are
good binary search trees,
which are relatively balanced,
something like this.
The height is log n.
We called unbalanced,
and that's good.
Anything order log n will be
fine.
In terms of searching,
it will then cost order log n.
And, there are bad binary
search trees which have really
large height,
possibly as big as n.
So, this is good,
and this is bad.
We'd sort of like to know,
we'd like to build binary
search trees in such a way that
they are good all the time,
or at least most of the time.
There are lots of ways to do
this, and in the next couple of
weeks, we will see four of them,
if you count the problem set,
I believe.
Today, we are going to use
randomization to make them
balanced most of the time in a
certain sense.
And then, in your problem set,
you will make that in a broader
sense.
But, one way to motivate this
topic, so I'm not going to
define randomly built binary
search trees for a little bit.
One way to motivate the topic
is through sorting,
our good friend.
So, there's a natural way to
sort n numbers using binary
search trees.
So, if I give you an array,
A, how would you sort that
array using binary search tree
operations as a black box?
Build the binary search tree,
and then traverse it in order.
Exactly.
So, let's say we have some
initial tree,
which is empty,
and then for each element of
the array, we insert it into the
tree.
That's what you meant by
building the search tree.
So, we insert AI into the tree.
This is the binary search tree
insertion, standard insertion.
And then, we do an in order
traversal, which in the book is
called in order tree walk.
OK, you should know these
algorithms are,
but just for very quick
reminder, tree insert basically
searches for that element AI
until it finds the place where
it should have been if it was in
the tree already,
and then adds a new leaf there
to insert that value.
Tree walk recursively walks the
left subtree,
then prints out the root,
and then recursively walks the
right subtree.
And, by the binary search tree
property, that will print the
elements out in sorted order.
So, let's do a quick example
because this turns out to be
related to another sorting
algorithm we've seen already.
So, while the example is
probably pretty trivial,
the connection is pretty
surprising.
At least, it was to me the
first time I taught this class.
So, my array is three,
one, eight, two,
six, seven, five.
And, I'm going to visit these
elements in order from left to
right, and just build a tree.
So, the first element I see is
three.
So, I insert three into an
empty tree.
That requires no comparisons.
Then I insert one.
I see, is one bigger or less
than three?
It's smaller.
So, I put it over here.
Then I insert eight.
That's bigger than three,
so it get's a new leaf over
here.
Then I insert two.
That sits between one and
three.
And so, it would fall off this
right child of one.
So, I add two there.
Six is bigger than three,
and less than eight.
So, it goes here.
Seven is bigger than three,
and less than eight,
bigger than six.
So, it goes here,
and five fits in between three
and five, three and six rather.
And so, that's the binary
search tree that again.
Then I run an in order
traversal, which will print one,
two, three, five,
six, seven, eight.
OK, I can run I quickly in my
head because I've got a big
stack.
I've got to be a little bit
careful.
Of course, you should check
that they come out in sorted
order: one, two,
three, five,
six, seven, eight.
And, if you don't have a big
stack, you can go and buy one.
That's always useful.
Memory costs are going up a bit
these days, or going down.
They should be because of
politics, but price-fixing,
or whatever.
So, the question is,
what's the running time of the
algorithm?
Here, this is one of those
answers where it depends.
The parts that are easy to
analyze are, well,
initialization.
The in order tree walk,
how long does that take?
n, good.
So, it's order n for the walk,
and for the initialization,
which is constant.
The question is,
how long does it take me to do
n tree inserts?
Anyone want to guess any kind
of answer to that question,
other than it depends?
I've already stolen the thunder
there.
Yeah?
Big Omega of n log n,
that's good.
It's at least n log n.
Why?
Right.
So, you gave two reasons.
The first one is because of the
decision tree lower bound.
That doesn't actually prove
this.
You have to be a little bit
careful.
This is a claim that it's omega
n log n all the time.
It's certainly omega n log n in
the worst case.
Every comparison-based sorting
algorithm is omega n log n in
the worst case.
It's also n log n every single
time, omega n log n because of
the second reason you gave,
which is the best thing that
could happen is we have a
perfectly balanced tree.
So, this is the figure that I
have drawn the most on a
blackboard in my life,
the perfect tree on 15 nodes,
I guess.
So, if we're lucky,
we have this.
And if you add up all the
depths of the nodes here,
which gives you the search tree
cost, in particular,
these n over two nodes in the
bottom, each have depth log n.
And, therefore,
you're going to have to pay it
least n log n for those.
And, if you're less balanced,
it's going to be even worse.
That takes some proving,
but it's true.
So, it's actually omega n log n
all the time.
OK, there are some cases,
like you do know that the
elements are almost already in
order, you can do it in linear
number comparisons.
But here, you can't.
Any other guesses at an answer
to this question?
Yeah?
Big O n^2?
Good, why?
Right.
We are doing n things,
and each node has depth,
at most, n.
So, the number of comparisons
we're making per element we
insert, is, at most,
n.
So that's, at most,
n^2.
Any other answers?
Is it possible for this
algorithm to take n^2 time?
Are there instances where it
takes theta n^2?
If it's already sorted,
that would be pretty bad.
So, if it's already sorted or
if it's reverse sorted,
you are in bad shape because
then you get a tree like this.
This is the sorted case.
And, you compute.
So, the total cost,
the time in general is going to
be the sum of the depths of the
nodes for each node,
X, in the tree.
And in this case,
it's one plus two plus three
plus four, this arithmetic
series.
There's n of them,
so this is theta n squared.
It's like n^2 over two.
So, that's bad news.
The worst-case running time of
this algorithm is n^2.
Does that sound familiar at
all, and algorithms worst-case
running time is n^2,
in particular,
in the already-sorted case?
But if we're lucky,
at the lucky case,
as we said, it's a balanced
tree.
Wouldn't that be great?
Anything with omega log n
height would give us a sorting
algorithm that runs in n log n.
So, in the lucky case,
we are n log n.
But in the unlucky case,
we are n^2 and unlucky use
sorted.
Does it remind you of any
algorithm we've seen before?
Quicksort.
It turns out the running time
of this algorithm is the same as
the running time of quicksort in
a very strong sense.
It turns out the comparisons
that this algorithm makes are
exactly the same comparisons
that quicksort makes.
It makes them in a different
order, but it's really the same
algorithm in disguise.
That's the surprise here.
So, in particular,
we've already analyzed
quicksort.
We should get something for
free out of that analysis.
So, the relation is,
BST sort and quicksort make the
same comparisons but in a
different order.
So, let me walk through the
same example we did before:
three, one, eight,
two, six, seven,
five.
So, there is an array.
We are going to run a
particular version of quicksort.
I have to be a little bit
careful here.
It's sort of the obvious
version of quicksort.
Remember, our standard,
boring quicksort is you take
the first element as the
partition element.
So, I'll take three here.
And, I split into the elements
less than three,
which is one and two.
And, the elements bigger than
three, which is eight,
six, seven, five.
And, in this version of
quicksort, I don't change the
order of the elements,
eight, six, seven,
five.
So, let's say the order is
preserved because only then will
this equivalence hold.
So, this is sort of a stable
partition algorithm.
It's easy enough to do.
It's a particular version of
quicksort.
And soon, we're going to
randomize it.
And after we randomize,
this difference doesn't matter.
OK, then on the left recursion,
we split in the partition
element.
There is things less than one,
which is nothing,
things bigger than one,
which is two.
And then, that's our partition
element.
We are done.
Over here, we partition on
eight.
Everything is less than eight.
So, we get six,
seven, five,
nothing on the right.
Then we partition at six.
We get things less than six,
mainly five,
things bigger than six,
mainly seven.
And, those are sort of
partition elements in a trivial
way.
Now, this tree that we get on
the partition elements looks an
awful lot like this tree.
OK, it should be exactly the
same tree.
And, you can walk through,
what comparisons does quicksort
make?
Well, first,
it compares everything to
three, OK, except three itself.
Now, if you look over here,
what happens when we are
inserting elements?
Well, each time we insert an
element, the first thing we do
is compare with three.
If it's less than,
we go to the left branch.
If it's greater than,
we go to the right branch.
So, we are making all these
comparisons with three in both
cases.
Then, if we have an element
less than three,
it's either one or two.
If it's one,
we're done.
No comparisons happen here one
to one.
But, we compare two to one.
And indeed, when we insert two
over there after comparing it to
three, we compare it to one.
And then we figure out that it
happens here.
Same thing happens in
quicksort.
For elements greater than
three, we compare everyone to
eight here because we are
partitioning with respect to
eight, and here because that's
the next node after three.
As soon as eight is inserted,
we compare everything with
eight to see in fact that's less
than eight, and so on:
so, all of the same
comparisons, just in a different
order.
So, we turn 90∞.
Kind of cool.
So, this has various
consequences in the analysis.
So, in particular,
the worst-case running time is
theta n^2, which is not so
exciting.
What we really care about is
the randomized version because
that's what performs well.
So, randomized BST sort is just
like randomized quicksort.
So, the first thing you do is
randomly permute the array
uniformly, picking all
permutations with equal
probability.
And then, we call BST sort.
OK, this is basically what
randomized quicksort could be
formulated as.
And then, randomized BST sort
is going to make exactly the
same comparisons as randomized
quicksort.
Here, we are picking the root
essentially randomly.
And here in quicksort,
you are picking the partition
elements randomly.
It's the same difference.
OK, so the time of this
algorithm equals the time of
randomized quicksort because we
are making the same comparisons.
So, the number of comparisons
is equal.
And this is true as random
variables.
The random variable,
the running time,
this algorithm is equal to the
random variable of this
algorithm.
In particular,
the expectations are the same.
OK, and we know that the
expected running time of
randomized quicksort on n
elements is?
Oh boy.
n log n.
Good.
I was a little worried there.
OK, so in particular,
the expected running time of
BST sort is n log n.
Obviously, this is not too
exciting from a sorting point of
view.
Sorting was just sort of to see
this connection.
What we actually care about,
and the reason I've introduced
this BST sort is what the tree
looks like.
What we really want is that
search tree.
The search tree can do more
than sort.
n order traversals are a pretty
boring thing to do with the
search tree.
You can search in a search
tree.
So, OK, that's still not so
exciting.
You could sort the elements and
then put them in an array and do
binary search.
But, the point of binary search
trees, instead of binary search
arrays, is that you can update
them dynamically.
We won't be updating them
dynamically in this lecture,
and we will in Wednesday and on
your problem set.
For now, it's just sort of
warm-up.
Let's say that the elements
aren't changing.
We are building one tree from
the beginning.
We have all n elements ahead of
time.
We are going to build it
randomly.
We randomly permute that array.
Then we throw all the elements
into a binary search tree.
That's what BST sort does.
Then it calls n order
traversal.
I don't really care about n
order traversal.
What I want,
because we've just analyzed it.
It would be a short lecture if
I were done.
What we want is this randomly
built BST, which is what we get
out of this algorithm.
So, this is the tree resulting
from randomized BST sort,
OK, resulting from randomly
permute in the array of just
inserting those elements using
the simple tree insert
algorithm.
The question is,
what does that tree look like?
And in particular,
is there anything we can
conclude out of this fact?
The expected running time of
BST sort is n log n.
OK, I've mentioned cursorily
what the running time of BST
sort is, several times.
It was the sum.
So, this is the time of BST
sort on n elements.
It's the sum over all nodes,
X, of the depth of that node.
OK, depth starts at zero and
works its way down because the
root element,
you don't make any comparisons
beyond that, you are making
whatever the depth is
comparisons.
OK, so we know that this thing
is, in expectation we know that
this is n log n.
What does that tell us about
the tree?
This is for all nodes,
X, in the tree.
Does it tell us anything about
the height of the tree,
for example?
Yeah?
Right, intuitively,
it says that the height of the
tree is theta log n,
and not n.
But, in fact,
it doesn't show that.
And that's why if you feel that
that's just intuition,
but it may not be quite right.
Indeed it's not.
Let me tell you what it does
say.
So, if we take expectation of
both sides, here we get n log n.
So, the expected value of that
is n log n.
So, over here,
well, we get the expected total
depth, which is not so exciting.
Let's look at the expected
average depth.
So, if I look at one over n,
the sum over all n nodes in the
tree of the depth of X,
that would be the average depth
over all the nodes.
And what I should get is theta
n log n over n because I divided
n on both sides.
And, I'm using,
here, linearity of expectation,
which is log n.
So, what this fact about the
expected running time tells me
is that the average depth in the
tree is log n,
which is not quite the height
of the tree being log n.
OK, remember the height of the
tree is the maximum depth of any
node.
Here, we are just bounding the
average depth.
Let's look at an example of a
tree.
I'll draw my favorite picture.
So, here we have a nice
balanced tree,
let's say, on half of the nodes
or a little more.
And then, I have one really
long path hanging off one
particular leaf.
It doesn't matter which one.
And, I'm going to say that this
path has length,
with a total height here,
I want to make root n,
which is a lot bigger than log
n.
This is roughly log n.
It's going to be log of n minus
root n, or so,
roughly.
So, most of the nodes have
logarithmic height and,
sorry, logarithmic depth.
If you compute the average
depth in this particular tree,
for most of the nodes,
let's say it's,
at most, n of the nodes have
height log n.
And then, there are root n
nodes, at most,
down here, which have depth,
at most, root n.
So, it's, at most,
root n times root n.
In fact, it's like half that,
but not a big deal.
So, this is n.
So, this is n log n,
or, sorry, average depth:
I have to divide everything by
n.
n log n would be rather large
for an average height,
average depth.
So, the average depth here is
log n, but the height of the
tree is square root of n.
So, this is not enough.
Just to know that the average
depth is log n doesn't mean that
the height is log n.
OK, but the claim is this
theorem for today is that the
expected height of a randomly
built binary search tree is
indeed log n.
BST is order log n.
This is what we like to know
because that tells us,
if we just build a binary
search tree randomly,
then we can search in it in log
n time.
OK, for sorting,
it's not as big a deal.
We just care about the expected
running time of creating the
thing.
Here, now we know that once we
prove this theorem,
we know that we can search
quickly in expectation,
in fact, most of the time.
So, the rest of today's lecture
will be proving this theorem.
It's quite tricky,
as you might imagine.
It's another big probability
analysis along the lines of
quicksort and everything.
So, I'm going to start with an
outline of the proof,
unless there are any questions
about the theorem.
It should be pretty clear what
we want to prove.
This is even weirder than most
of the analyses we've seen.
It's going to use a fancy
trick, which is exponentiating a
random variable.
And to do that we need a tool
called Jenson's inequality.
We are going to prove that
tool.
Usually, we don't prove
probability tools.
But this one we are going to
prove.
It's not too hard.
It's also basic analysis.
So, the lemma,
says that if we have what's
called to a convex function,
f, and you should all know what
that means, but I'll define it
soon in case you have forgotten.
If you have a convex function,
f, and you have a random
variable, X, you take f of the
expectation.
That's, at most,
the expectation of f of that
random variable.
Think about it enough and draw
a convex function that is fairly
intuitive, I guess.
But we will prove it.
What that allows us to do is
instead of analyzing the random
variable that tells us the
height of a tree,
so, X_n I'll call the random
variable, RV,
of the height of a BST,
randomly constructed BST on n
nodes we will analyze.
Well, instead of analyzing this
desired random variable,
X_n, sorry, this should have
been in capital X.
We can analyze any convex
function of X_n.
And, we're going to analyze the
exponentiation.
So, I'm going to define Y_n to
be two to the power of X_n.
OK, the big question here is
why bother doing this?
The answer is because it works
and it wouldn't work if we
analyze X_n.
We will see some intuition of
that later on,
but it's not very intuitive.
This is our analysis where you
need this extra trick.
So, we're going to bound the
expectation of Y_n,
and from that,
and using Jensen's inequality,
we're going to get a bound on
the expectation of X_n,
a pretty tight bound,
actually, because if we can
bound the exponent up to
constant factors,
the exponentiation up to
we can bound X_n even better
because you take logs to get
X_n.
So, we will even figure out
what the constant is.
So, what we will prove,
this is the heart of the proof,
is that the expected value of
Y_n is order n^3.
Here, we won't really know what
the constant is.
We don't need to.
And then, we put these pieces
together.
So, let's do that.
What we really care about is
the expectation of X_n,
which is the height of our
tree.
What we find out about is this
fact.
So, leave some horizontal space
here.
We get the expectation of two
to the X_n.
That's the expectation of Y_n.
So, we learned that that's
order n^3.
And, Jensen's inequality tells
us that if we take this
function, two to the X,
we plug it in here,
that on the left-hand side we
get two to the E of X.
So, we get two to the E of X_n
is at most E of two to the X_n.
So, that's where we use
Jensen's inequality,
because what we care about is E
of X_n.
So now, we have a bound.
We say, well,
two to the E of X_n is,
at most, n^3.
So, if we take the log of both
sides, we get E of X_n is,
at most, the log of n^3.
OK, I will write it in this
funny way, log of order n^3,
which will actually tell us the
constant.
This is three log n plus order
one.
So, we will prove that the
expected height of a randomly
constructed binary search tree
on n nodes is roughly three log
n, at most.
OK, I will say more about that
later.
So, you've now seen the end of
the proof.
That's the foreshadowing.
And now, this is the top-down
approach.
So, you sort of see what the
steps are.
Now, we just have to do the
steps.
OK, step one:
take a bit of work,
but it's easy because it's
pretty basic stuff.
Step two is just a definition
and we are done.
Step three is probably the
hardest part.
Step four, we've already done.
So, let's start with step one.
So, the first thing I need to
do is define a convex function
because we are going to
manipulate the definition a fair
amount.
So, this is a notion from real
analysis.
Analysis is a fancy word for
calculus if you haven't taken
the proper analysis class.
You should have seen convexity
in any calculus class.
A convex function is one that
looks like this.
OK, good.
One way to formalize that
notion is to consider any two
points on this curve.
So, I'm only interested in
functions from reals to reals.
So, it looks like this.
This is f of something.
And, this is the something.
If I take two points on this
curve, and I draw a line segment
connecting them,
that line segment is always
above the curve.
That's the meaning of
convexity.
It has a geometric notion,
which is basically the same.
But for functions,
this line segment should stay
above the curve.
The line does not stay above
the curve.
If I extended it farther,
it goes beneath the curve,
of course.
But, that segment should.
So, I'm going to formalize that
a little bit.
I'll call this x,
and then this is f of x.
And, I'll call this y,
and this is f of y.
So, the claim is that I take
any number between x and y,
and I look up,
and I say, OK,
here's the point on the curve.
Here's the point on the line
segment.
The value of that point on the
y value, here,
should be greater than or equal
to the y value here,
OK?
To figure out what the point
is, we need some,
I would call it geometry.
I'm sure it's an analysis
concept, too.
But, I'm a geometer,
so I get to call it geometry.
If you have two points,
p and q, and you want to
parameterize this line segment
between them,
so, I want to parameterize some
points here, the way to do it is
to take a linear combination.
And, if you should have taken
some linear algebra,
linear combination look
something like this.
And, in fact,
we're going to take something
called an affine combination
where alpha plus beta equals
one.
It turns out,
if you take all such points,
some number,
alpha, times the point,
p, plus some number,
beta times the point,
q, where alpha plus beta equals
one.
If you take all those points,
you get the entire line here,
which is nifty.
But, we don't want the entire
line.
If you also constrained alpha
and beta to be nonnegative,
you just get this line segment.
So, this forces alpha and beta
to be between zero and one
because they have to sum to one,
and they are nonnegative.
So, what we are going to do
here is take alpha times x plus
beta times y.
That's going to be our point
between with these constraints:
alpha plus beta equals one.
Alpha and beta are greater than
or equal to zero.
Then, this point is f of that.
This is f of alpha x plus beta,
y.
And, this point is the linear
interpolation between f of x and
f of y, the same one.
So, it's alpha times f of x
plus beta times f of y.
OK, that's the intuition.
If you didn't follow it,
it's not too big a deal because
all we care about are the
symbolic answer for proving
things.
But, that's where this comes
from.
So, here's the definition.
Its function is convex.
If, for all x and y,
and all alpha and beta are
greater than or equal to zero,
whose sum is one,
we have f of alpha x plus beta
y is less than or equal to alpha
f of x plus beta f of y.
So, that's just saying that
this y coordinate here is less
than or equal to this y
coordinate.
OK, but that's the symbolism
behind that picture.
OK, so now we want to prove
Jensen's inequality.
OK, we're not quite there yet.
We are going to prove a simple
lemma, from which it will be
easy to derive Jenson's
equality.
So, this is the theorem we are
proving.
So, here's a lemma about convex
functions.
You may have seen it before.
It will be crucial to Jensen's
inequality.
So, suppose,
this is a statement about
affine combinations of n things
instead of two things.
So, this will say that
convexity can be generalized to
taking n things.
So, suppose we have n real
numbers, and we have n values
alpha i, alpha one up to alpha
n.
They are all nonnegative.
And, their sum is one.
So, the sum of alpha k,
I guess, k equals one to n,
is one.
So, those are the assumptions.
The conclusion is the same
thing, but summing over all k.
So, k equals one to n,
alpha_k * x_k.
Take f of that versus taking
the sum of the alphas times the
f's.
k equals one to n.
So, the definition of convexity
is exactly that statement,
but where n equals two.
OK, alpha one and alpha two are
alpha and beta.
This is just a statement for
general n.
And, you can interpret this in
some funnier way,
which I won't get into.
Oh, sure, why not?
I'm a geometer.
So, this is saying you take
several points on this curve.
You take the polygon that they
define.
So, these are straight-line
segments.
You take the interior.
If you take an affine
combination like that,
you will get a point inside
that polygon,
or possibly on the boundary.
The claim is that all those
points are above the curve.
Again, intuitively:
true if you draw a nice,
canonical convex curve,
but in fact,
it's true algebraically,
too.
It's always a good thing.
Any suggestions on how we might
prove this theorem,
this lemma?
It's pretty easy.
So, what technique might we use
to prove it?
One word: induction.
Always a good answer,
yeah.
Induction should shout out at
you here because we already know
that this is true by definition
of convexity for n equals two.
So, the base case is clear.
In fact, there's an even
simpler base case,
which is when n equals one.
If n equals one,
then you have one number that
sums to one.
So, alpha one is one.
And so, nothing is going on
here.
This is just saying that f of
one times x_1 is,
at most, one times f of x_1:
so, not terribly exciting
because that holds with the
quality.
OK, so we don't even need the n
equals two base case.
So, the interesting part,
although still not terribly
interesting, is the induction
step.
This is good practice in
induction.
So, what we care about is this
f of this linear combination,
f on combination,
x_k times x_k summed over all
k.
Now, what I would like to do is
apply induction.
What I know about inductively,
is say f of this sum,
if it's summed only up to n
minus one instead of all the way
up to n.
Any smaller sum I can deal with
by induction.
So, I'm going to try and get
rid of the nth term.
I want to separate it out.
And, this is fairly natural if
you've played with affine
combinations before.
But it's just some algebra.
So, I want to separate out the
alpha_n*x_n term.
And, I'd also like to make it
an affine combination.
This is the trick.
Sorry, no f here.
If I just removed the last
term, the alpha k's from one up
to n minus one wouldn't sum to
one anymore.
They'd sum to something
smaller.
So, I can't just take out this
term.
I'm going to have to do some
trickery here,
x_k plus the f.
Good.
So, you should see why this is
true, because the one minus
alpha n's cancel.
And then, I'm just getting the
sum of alpha_k*x_k,
k equals one to n minus one,
plus the alpha_n*x_n term.
So, I haven't done anything
here.
These are equal.
But now, I have this nifty
feature, that on the one hand,
these two numbers,
alpha n and one minus alpha n
sum to one.
And on the other hand,
if I did it right,
these numbers should sum up to
one just going from one up to n
minus one.
Why do they sum up to one?
Well, these numbers summed up
to one minus alpha n.
And so, I'm dividing everything
by one minus alpha n.
So, they will sum to one.
So now, I have two affine
combinations.
I just apply the two things
that I know.
I know this affine combination
will work because,
well, why?
Why can I say that this is
alpha n f of x_n plus one minus
alpha n f of this crazy sum?
Shout it out.
There are two possible answers.
One is correct,
and one is incorrect.
So, which will it be?
This should have been less than
or equal to.
That's important.
It's on the board.
It can't be too difficult.
So, I'm treating this as just
one big X value.
So, I have some x_n,
and I have some crazy X.
I want f of the affine
combination of those two X
values is, at most,
the affine combinations of the
f's of those X values.
This is?
It is the inductive hypothesis
where n equals two.
Unfortunately,
we didn't prove the n equals
two case is a special base case.
So, we can't use induction here
the way that I've stated the
base case.
If you did n equals two base
case, you can do that.
Here, we can't.
So, the other answer is by
convexity, good.
That's right here.
So, f is convex.
We know that this is true for
any two X values,
and provided these two sum to
one.
So, we know that this is true.
Now is when we apply induction.
So, now we are going to
manipulate this right term by
induction.
See, before we didn't
necessarily know that n was
bigger than two.
But, we know that n is bigger
than n minus one.
That much, I can be sure of.
So, this is one minus alpha n
times the sum,
k equals one to n minus one of
alpha k over one minus alpha n
times f of x_k,
if I got that right.
This is by induction,
the induction hypothesis,
because these alpha k's over
one minus alpha n sum to one.
Now, these one minus alpha n's
cancel, and we just get what we
want.
This is sum k equals one to n
of alpha k, f of x_k.
So, we get f of the sum is,
at most, sum of the f's.
That proves the lemma.
OK, a bit tedious,
but each step is pretty
straightforward.
Do you agree?
Now, it turns out to be
relatively straightforward to
prove Jensen's inequality.
That's the magic.
And then, we get to do the
expectation analysis.
So, we use our good friends,
indicator random variables.
OK, but for now,
we just want to prove this
statement.
If we have a convex function,
f of the expectation is,
at most, expectation of f of
that random variable.
OK, this is a random variable,
right?
If you want to sample from this
random variable,
you sample from X,
and then you apply f to it.
That's the meaning of this
notation, f of X because X is a
random variable.
We get to use that f is convex.
OK, it turns out this is not
hard, if you remember the
definition of expectation,
oh, I want to make one more
assumption here,
which is that X is integral.
So, it's an integer random
variable, meaning it takes
integer values.
OK, that's all we care about
because we're looking at running
times.
This statement is true for
continuous random variables,
too, but I would like to do the
discrete case because then I get
to write down what U of X is.
So, what is the definition of E
of X?
X only takes on integer values.
This is easy,
but you have to remember it.
It's a good drill.
I don't really know much about
X except that it takes on
integer values.
Any suggestions on how I should
expand the expectation of X?
How many people know this by
heart?
OK, it's not too easy then.
Well, expectation has something
to do with probability,
right?
So, I should be looking at
something like the probability
that X equals some value,
x.
That would seem like a good
thing to do.
What else goes here?
A sum, yeah.
The sum, well,
X could be somewhere between
minus infinity and infinity.
That's certainly true.
And, we have some more.
There's something missing here.
What is this sum?
What does it come out to for
any random variable,
X, that takes on integer
values?
One, good.
So, I need to add in something
here, namely X.
OK, that's the definition of
the expectation.
Now, f of a sum of things,
where these coefficients sum to
one looks an awful lot like the
lemma that we just proved.
OK, we proved it in the finite
case.
It turns out,
it holds just as well if you
take all integers.
So, I'm just going to assume
that.
So, I have these probabilities,
these alpha values sum to one.
Therefore, I can use this
inequality, that this is,
at most, let me get this right,
I have the alphas,
so I have a sum,
x equals minus infinity to
infinity of the alphas,
which are a probability;
capital X equals little x times
f of the value,
f of little x.
OK, so there it is.
I've used the lemma.
So, maybe now I'll erase the
lemma.
OK, I cheated by using the
countable version of the lemma
while only proving the finite
case.
It's all I can do in lecture.
So, this is by a lemma.
Now, what I'd like to prove and
leave some blank space here is
this is, at most,
E of f of X,
so that this summation is,
at most, E of f of X.
Actually, it's equal to E of f
of X.
And, it really looks kind of
equal, right?
You've got sum of some
probabilities times f of X.
It almost looks like the
definition of E of f of X,
but it isn't.
You've got to be a little bit
careful because E of f of X
should talk about the
probability that f of X equals a
particular value.
We can relate these as follows.
It's not too hard.
You can look at each value that
f takes on, and then look at all
the values, k,
that map to that value,
x.
So all the k's where f of X
equals x, the probability that X
equals k, OK,
this is another way of writing
the probability that f of X
equals x.
OK, so, in other words,
I'm grouping the terms in a
particular way.
I'm saying, well,
f of X takes on various values.
Clever me to switch.
I used to use k's unannounced,
so I better call this something
else.
Let's call this Y,
sorry, switch notation here.
It makes sense.
I should look at the
probability that X equals x.
So, what I really care about is
what this f of X value takes on.
Let's just call it Y,
look at all the values,
Y, that f could take on.
That's the range of f.
And then, I'll look at all the
different values of X where f of
X equals Y.
If I add up those
probabilities,
because these are different
values of X.
Those are sort of independent
events.
So, this summation will be the
probability that f of X equals
Y.
This is capital X.
This is little y.
And then, if I multiply that by
y, I'm getting the expectation
of f of X.
So, think about this,
these two inequalities hold.
This may be a bit bizarre here
because these sums are
potentially infinite.
But, it's true.
OK, this proves Jensen's
inequality.
So, it wasn't very hard,
just a couple of boards,
once we had this powerful
convexity lemma.
So, we just used convexity.
We used the definition of E of
X.
We used convexity.
That lets us put the f's
inside.
Then we do this regrouping of
terms, and we figure out,
oh, that's just E of f of X.
So, the only inequality here is
coming from convexity.
All right, now comes the
algorithms.
So, this was just some basic
probability stuff,
which is good to practice.
OK, we could see in the quiz,
which is not surprising.
This is the case for me,
too.
You have a lot of intuition
with algorithms.
Whenever it's algorithmic,
it makes a lot of sense because
you're sort of grounded in some
things that you know because you
are computer scientists,
or something of that ilk.
For the purposes of this class,
you are computer scientists.
But, with sort of the basic
probability, unless you happen
to be a mathematician,
it's less intuitive,
and therefore harder to get
fast.
And, in quiz one,
speed is pretty important.
On the final,
speed will also be important.
The take home certainly doesn't
hurt.
So, the take home is more
interesting because it requires
being clever.
You have to actually be
creative.
And, that really tests
algorithmic design.
So far, we've mainly tested
analysis, and just,
can you work through
probability?
Can you figure out what the,
can you remember what your
running time of randomized
quicksort is,
and so on?
Quiz two will actually test
creativity because you have more
time.
It's hard to be creative in two
hours.
OK, so we want to analyze the
expected height of a randomly
constructed binary search tree.
So, I've defined this before,
but let me repeat it because it
was a while ago almost at the
beginning of lecture.
I'm going to take the random
variable of the height of a
randomly built binary search
tree on n nodes.
So, that was randomized,
the n values.
Take a random permutation,
insert them one by one from
left to right with tree insert.
What is the height of the tree
that you get?
What is the maximum depth of
any node?
I'm not going to look so much
at X_n.
I'm going to look at the
exponentiation of X_n.
And, still we have no intuition
why.
But, two to the X is a convex
function.
OK, it looks like that.
It's very sharp.
That's the best I can do for
drawing, two to the X.
You saw how I drew my
histogram.
So, we want to somehow write
this random variable as
something, OK,
in some algebra.
The main thing here is to split
into cases.
That's how we usually go
because there's lots of
different scenarios on what
happens.
So, I mean, how do we construct
a tree from the beginning?
First thing we do is we take
the first node.
We throw it in,
make it the root.
OK, so whatever the first value
happens to be in the array,
which we don't really know how
that falls into sorted order,
we put it at the root.
And, it stays the root.
We never change the root from
then on.
Now, of all the remaining
elements, some of them are less
than this value,
and they go over here.
So, let's call this r at the
root.
And, some of them are greater
than r.
So, they go over here.
Maybe there's more over here.
Who knows?
Arbitrary partition,
in fact, uniformly random
partition, which should sound
familiar, whether there are k
elements over here,
and n minus k minus one
for any value of k,
that's equally likely because
this is chosen uniformly.
The root is chosen uniformly.
It's the first element in a
random permutation.
So, what I'm going to do is
parameterize by that.
How many elements are over
here, and how many elements are
over here?
Because this thing is,
again, a randomly built binary
search tree on however many
nodes are in there because after
I pick r, it's determined who is
to the left and who is to the
right.
And so, I can just partition.
It's like running quicksort.
I partition the elements left
of r, the elements right of r,
and I'm sort of recursively
constructing a randomly built
binary search tree on those two
sub-permutations because
sub-permutations of uniform
permutations are uniform.
OK, so these are essentially
recursive problems.
And, we know how to analyze
All we need to know is that
there are k minus one elements
over here, and n minus k
elements over here.
And, that would mean that r has
rank k, remember,
rank in the sense of the index
in assorted order.
So, where should I go?
So, if the root,
r, has rank,
k, so if this is a statement
about condition on this event,
which is a random event,
then what we have is X_n equals
one plus the max of X_(k minus
one), X_(n minus k) because the
height of this tree is the max
of the heights of the two
subtrees plus one because we
have one more level up top.
OK, so that's the natural thing
to do.
What we are trying to analyze,
though, is Y_n.
So, for Y_n,
we have to take two to this
power.
So, it's two times the max of
two to the X_(k minus one),
which is Y_(k minus one),
and two to this,
which is Y_(n minus k).
And, now you start to see,
maybe, why we are interested in
Y's instead of X's in the sense
that it's what we know how to
do.
When we solve a recursion,
when we solve,
like, the expected running
time, we haven't taken
expectations,
yet, here.
But, when we compute the
expected running time of
quicksort, we have something
like two times,
I mean, we have a couple of
recursive subproblems,
which are being added together.
OK, here, we have a factor of
two.
Here, we have a max.
But, intuitively,
we know how to multiply random
variables by a constant because
that's, like,
there's two recursive
subproblems of the size is equal
to the max of these two,
which we don't happen to know
here.
But, there it is,
whereas one plus,
we don't know how to handle so
well.
And, indeed,
our techniques are really good
at solving recurrences,
except up to the constant
factors.
And, this one plus really
doesn't affect the constant
factor too much,
it would seem.
OK, but it's a big deal.
In exponentiation,
it's a factor of two.
So here, it's really hard to
see what this one plus is doing.
And, our analysis,
if we tried it,
and it's a good idea to try it
at home and see what happens,
if you tried to do what I'm
about to do with X_n,
the one plus will sort of get
lost, and you won't get a bound.
You just can't prove anything.
With a factor of two,
we're in good shape.
We sort of know how to deal
with that.
We'll say more when we've
actually done the proof about
why we use Y_n instead of X_n.
But for now,
we're using Y_n.
So, this is sort of a
recursion, except it's
conditioned on this event.
So, how do I turn this into a
statement that holds all the
time?
Sorry?
Divide by the probability of
the event?
More or less.
Indeed, these events are
independent.
Or, they're all equally likely,
I should say.
They're not independent.
In fact, one determines all the
others.
So, how do I generally
represent an event in algebra?
Indicator random variables:
good.
Remember your friends,
indicator random variables.
All of these analyses use
So, they will just represent
this event, and we'll call it
Z_nk.
It's going to be one if the
root has rank,
k, and zero otherwise.
So, in particular,
the probability of,
these things are all equally
likely for, a particular value
of n if you try all the values
of k.
The probability that this
equals one, which is also the
expectation of that indicator
random variable,
which you should know,
is it only takes values one or
zero.
The zero doesn't matter in the
expectation.
So, this is going to be,
hopefully, one over n if I got
01:04:34,034 --> 00:00:00,000
right.
So, there are n possibility of
what the rank of the root could
be.
Each of them are equally likely
because we have a uniform
permutation.
So, now, I can rewrite this
condition statement as a
summation where the Z_nk's will
let me choose what case I'm in.
So, we have Y_n is the sum,
k equals one to n of Z_nk times
two times the max of X,
sorry, Y, k minus one,
Y_n minus k.
So, now we have our good
friend, the recurrence.
We need to solve it.
OK, we can't really solve it
because this is a random
variable, and it's talking about
recursive random variables.
So, we first take the
expectation of both sides.
That's the only thing we can
really bound.
Y_n could be n^2 in an unlucky
case, sorry, not n^2.
It could be n^2.
It could be two to the,
boy, two to the n if you are
unlucky because X_n could be as
big as n, the height of the
tree.
And, Y_n is two to that.
So, it could be two to the n.
What we want to prove is that
it's polynomial in n.
If it's n to some constant,
and we take logs,
it'll be order log n.
OK, so we'll take the
expectation, and hopefully that
will guarantee that this holds.
OK, so we have expectation of
this summation of random
variables times recursive random
variables.
So, what is the first,
woops, I forgot a bracket.
What is the first thing that we
do in this analysis?
This should,
yeah, linearity of expectation.
That one's easy to remember.
OK, we have a sum.
So, let's put the E inside.
OK, now we have the expectation
of our product.
What should we use?
Independence.
Hopefully, things are
independent.
And then, we could write this.
Then, it would be the
expectation of the product.
And, heck, let's put the two
outside, because it's not,
no sense in keeping it in here.
Y is there starting to look
like X's?
I can't even read them.
Sorry about that.
This should all be Y's.
OK, very wise,
random variables.
So.
Why are these independent?
So, here we are looking at the
choice of what the root is,
what rank the root has in a
problem of size n.
In here, we're looking at what
the root, I mean,
there are various choices of
what the search tree looks like
in the stuff left of the root,
and in the stuff right of the
root.
Those are independent choices
because everything is uniform
here.
So, the choice of this guy was
uniform.
And then, that determines who
partitions in the left and the
right.
Those are completely
independent recursive choices of
who's the root in the left
subtree?
Who's the root in the left of
the left subtree,
and so on?
So, this is a little trickier
than usual.
Before, it was random choices
in the algorithm.
Now, it's in some construction
where we choose the random
numbers ahead of time.
It's a bit funny,
but this is still independent.
So, we get this just like we
did in quicksort,
and so on.
OK.
Now, we continue.
And, now it's time to be a bit
sloppy.
Well, one of these things we
know.
OK, E of ZNK,
that, we wrote over here.
It's one over n.
So, that's cool.
So, we get a two over n
outside, and we get this sum of
the expectation of a max of
these two things.
Normally, we would write,
well, I think sometimes you
write T of max,
or Y of the max of the two
things here.
You've got to write it as the
max of these two variables.
And, the trick,
I mean, it's not too much of a
trick, is that the max is,
at most, the sum.
So, we have nonnegative things.
So, we have two over n,
sum k equals one to n of the
expectation of the sum instead
of the max.
OK, this is,
in some sense,
the key step where we are
losing something in our bound.
So far, we've been exact.
Now, we're being pretty sloppy.
It's true the max is,
at most, the sum.
But, it's a pretty loose upper
bound as things go.
We'll keep that in mind for
later.
What else can we do with the
summation?
This should,
again, look familiar.
Now that we have a sum of a sum
of two things,
I'm trying to like it to be a
sum of one thing.
Sorry?
You can use linearity of
expectation, good.
So, that's the first thing I
should do.
So, linearity of expectation
lets me separate that.
Now I have a sum of 2n things.
Right, I could break that into
the sum of these guys,
and the sum of these guys.
Do you know anything about
those two sums?
Do we know anything about those
two sums?
They're the same.
In fact, every term here is
appearing exactly twice.
One says a k minus one.
One says an n minus k,
and that even works if it's
odd, I think.
So, in fact,
we can just take one of the
sums and multiply it by two.
So, this is four over n times
the sum, and I'll rewrite it a
little bit from zero to n minus
one of E of Y_k.
Just check the number of times
each Y_k appears from zero up to
n minus one is exactly two.
So, now I have a recurrence.
I have E of Y_n is,
at most, this thing.
Let's just write that for our
memory.
So, how's that?
Cool.
Now, I just have to solve the
recurrence.
How should I solve an ugly,
hairy, recurrence like this?
Substitution:
yea!
Not the master method.
OK, it's a pretty nasty
recurrence.
So, I'm going to make a guess,
and I've already told you the
guess, that it's n^3.
I think n^3 is pretty much
exactly where this proof will be
obtainable.
So, substitution method,
substitution method is just a
proof by induction.
And, there are two things every
proof by induction should have,
well, almost every proof by
induction, unless you're being
fancy.
It should have a base case,
and the base case here is n
equals order one.
I didn't write it,
but, of course,
if you have a constant size
tree, it has constant height.
So, this thing will be true as
long as we set true if c is
sufficiently large.
OK, so, don't forget that.
A lot of people forgot it on
the quiz.
We even mentioned the base
case.
Usually, we don't even mention
the base case.
And, you should assume that
there's one there.
And, you have to say this in
any proof by substitution.
OK, now, we have the induction
step.
So, I claim that E of Y_n is,
at most, Ccof n^3,
assuming that it's true for
smaller n.
You should write the induction
hypothesis here,
but I'm going to skip it
because I'm running out of time.
Now, we have this recurrence
that E of Y_n is,
at most, this thing.
So, E of Y_n is,
at most, four over n,
sum k equals zero to n minus
one of E of Y_k.
Now, notice that k is always
smaller than n.
So, we can apply induction.
So, this is,
at most, four over n,
sum k equals zero to n minus
one of c times k^3.
That's the induction
hypothesis.
Cool.
Now, I need an upper bound on
this sum, if you have a good
memory, then you know a closed
form for this sum.
But, I don't have such a good
memory as I used to.
I never memorized this sum when
I was a kid, so I don't remember
everything when I memorize when
I was less than 12 years old.
I still remember all the digits
of pi, whatever.
But, anything I try to memorize
now just doesn't quite stick the
same way.
So, I don't happen to know this
sum.
What's a good way to
approximate this sum?
Integral: good.
So, in fact,
I'm going to take the c
outside.
So, this is 4c over n.
The sum is, at most,
the integral.
If you get the range right,
so, you have to go one larger.
Instead of n minus one,
you go up to n.
This is in the textbook.
It's intuitive,
too, as long as you have a
monotone function.
That's key.
So, you have something that's
like this.
And, you know,
the sum is taking each of these
and weighting them with a value
of one.
The integral is computing the
area under this curve.
So, in particular,
if you look at this
approximation of the integral,
then, I mean,
this thing is certainly,
this would be the sum if you go
one larger at the end,
and that's, at most,
the integral.
So, that's proof by picture.
But, you can see this in the
book.
You should know it from 042 I
guess.
Now, integrals,
hopefully, you can solve.
Integral of x^3 is x^4 over
four.
I got it right.
And then, we're valuing that at
n.
And, it's zero.
Subtracting the zero doesn't
matter because zero to the
fourth power is zero.
So, it's just n^4 over four.
So, this is 4c over n times n^4
over four.
And, conveniently,
this four cancels with this
four.
The four turns into a three
because of this,
and we get n^3.
We get cn^3.
Damn convenient,
because that's what we wanted
to prove.
OK, so this proof is just
barely snaking by:
no residual term.
We've been sloppy all over the
place, and yet we were really
lucky.
And, we were just sloppy in the
right places.
So, this is a very tricky
proof.
If you just tried to do it by
hand, it's pretty easy to be too
sloppy, and not get quite the
right answer.
But, this just barely works.
So, let me say a couple of
things about it in my remaining
one minute.
So, we can do the conclusion,
again.
I won't write it because I
don't have time,
but here it is.
We just proved a bound on Y_n,
which was two to the power X_n.
What we cared about was X_n.
So, we used Jensen's
inequality.
We get the two to the E of X_n
is, at most, E of two to the
X_n.
This is what we know about
because that's Y_n.
So, we know E of Y_n is now
order n^3.
OK, we had to set this constant
sufficiently large for the base
case.
We didn't really figure out
what the constant was here.
It didn't matter because now
we're taking the logs of both
sides.
We get E of X_n is,
at most, log of order n^3.
This constant is a
multiplicative constant.
So, you take the logs.
It becomes additive.
This constant is an exponent.
So, it would take logs.
It becomes a multiple.
Three log n plus order one.
This is a pretty damn tight
bound on the height of a
randomly built binary search
tree, the expected height,
I should say.
In fact, the expected height of
X_n is equal to,
well, roughly,
I'll just say it's roughly,
I don't want to be too precise
here, 2.9882 times log n.
This is the result by a friend
of mine, Luke Devroy,
if I spell it right,
in 1986.
He's a professor at McGill
University in Montreal.
So, we're pretty close,
three to 2.98.
And, I won't prove this here.
The hard part here is actually
the lower bound,
but it's only that much.
I should say a little bit more
about why we use Y_n instead of
X_n.
And, it's all about the
sloppiness.
And, in particular,
this step, where we said that
the max of these two random
variables is,
at most, the sum.
And, while that's true for X
just as well as it is true for
Y, it's more true for Y.
OK, this is a bit weird
because, remember,
what we're analyzing here is
all possible values of k.
This has to work no matter what
k is, in some sense.
I mean, we're bounding all of
those cases simultaneously,
the sum of them all.
So, here we're looking at k
minus one versus n minus k.
And, in fact,
here, there's a polynomial
version.
But, so, if you take two values
a and b, and you say,
well, max of ab is,
at most, a plus b.
And, on the other hand you say,
well, max of two to the a and
two to the b is,
at most, two to the a plus two
to the b.
Doesn't this feel better than
that?
Well, they are,
of course, the same.
But, if you look at a minus b,
as that grows,
this becomes a tighter bound
faster than this becomes a
tighter bound because here we're
looking at absolute difference
between a minus b.
So, that's why this is pretty
good and this is pretty bad.
We're still really bad if a and
b are almost the same.
But, we're trying to solve this
for all partitions into k minus
one and n minus k.
So, it's OK if we get a few of
the cases wrong in the middle
where it evenly partitions.
But, as soon as we get some
skew, this will be very close to
this, whereas this will be still
pretty far from this.
You have to get pretty close to
the edge before you're not
losing much here,
whereas pretty quickly you're
not losing much here.
That's the intuition.
Try it, and see what happens
with X_n, and it won't work.
See you Wednesday.